Alex here with the game spot news update
PlayStation boss Scott rody fondly
remembers the moment last year when
microsoft announced that its Xbox one
will be a hundred dollars more than the
PlayStation 4 and an interview with ars
technica rody said we were in press
conference rehearsals last year we had a
feeling Microsoft was going to come in
at four hundred ninety nine dollars but
we weren't sure so yeah we were dancing
in the aisles and hi papi it was great
Sony coming in under Microsoft on price
point is new for this console generation
due to the success of the PlayStation 2
Sony was very confident that the
PlayStation 3 would succeed rohde said
we thought we could overcome Microsoft
in the previous generation because the
first Xbox didn't have that great market
penetration and PlayStation 2 was so
dominant in that era we completely
misjudged how much the market will bear
in terms of a price point while the
PlayStation 4 has been out selling the
xbox one there's still plenty of time
left for Microsoft to increase sales a
connectionless version of xbox one just
went on sale in early June for 399
dollars putting it in line with the
playstation 4 and gamestop has said that
the console is flying off the shelves
we'll have a better idea of where things
stand in the post connect era when MPD
releases sales figures for June early
next month for more hardware and news
keep it locked to gamespot com